joining us now live from Milton Keynes
is the actor Warwick Davis all right
thank you so much for talking to us here
on Sky News we appreciate your time I'm
just heartbreaking isn't it to watch
that video of kweilyn when you watched
it how did you feel I mean it is deeply
saddening to to see the video and how
upset Croydon is but sadly this is all
too common and occurrence
you know especially for children who are
physically different and I actually run
a charity called Little People UK and we
see a lot of cases of bullying in
schools without members and you know
you'd think in today's world would be
better educated and our children would
be educated to to respect others and to
care for us and but it doesn't seem to
be getting any better no it doesn't and
when you were young did you ever have to
deal with anything the Queen has been
through we know I did experience
bullying and that the way I got around
it fortunately my parents you know
instilled this great sense of self
belief and self-worth in me and and made
me feel confident at home and I took
that confidence into school with me and
at first it was a bit of acting I kind
of acted like I was really confident and
I noticed then the bullying kind of
calmed down a bit and the more it calmed
down the more confident I then felt and
it became self-perpetuating and
eventually I didn't have to fake it
anymore
I was confident and the bullying stopped
but in Quaid's position you know he's in
a very low place right now because he
feels you know he's got no self esteem
and fortunately all these messages were
support from around the world which have
been wonderful and that'll do him a
great deal of good in in feeling good
about himself again and you know
hopefully he can now kind of pick
himself up and and overcome this but
it's terribly difficult and you know
schools now kind of powerless teachers
can do less discipline nowadays than
when I was at school and and so
therefore these bullies they could get
away with it and they they they see
somebody with dwarfism like Wayne as
being a weaker person even though he
isn't that's how they see it because
bullies
Angelia cowards and and we'll pick on
somebody they feel they're not going to
get retaliation from